let me ask this bro because obviously we
know what happened but a week or so ago
or can we joke about it now do you guys
joke about it Jose doesn't like it he
doesn't like joking about it he doesn't
like it at all he didn't want to be in
that situation it happened the Tigers
were here and we honored Mickey because
he's retiring this year we gave him a
nice guitar Jose's holding the guitar
and he goes to give him the guitar and
maybe like does this little like square
up with him and Jose is just like
I want no parts uh so he didn't even
like the joke he's like super
non-confrontational and he doesn't want
it like being brought up over and over
like he's like it happened it is what it
is it's behind me I don't want no parts
okay all right well it is I won't joke
with